Before we do some exercises,
I want you to go back to Xcode and
open up the Maze project.
Once you have it open, I want you
to navigate to the Move.swift file.
It's located under Maze > UnderTheHood
> MazeMoves, and then Move.swift.
This is where we describe
the Move struct.
But it's just a single file, and
that seems a little confusing.
Since the robot is
moving more than once,
don't we need more than one Move struct,
or more than one Move.swift file?
The answer is no.
Think back to the analogies we used,
like engine blueprints.
In the blueprints, a particular
component was defined only once.
But actual instances of the component
will physically exist in tens and
thousands of actual engines.
And that's what this file is.
It's like the blueprint for
the Move struct.
We create this single blueprint, as we
can see here in the Move.swift file, and
then we can create many instances of
the Move struct in our application.
In programming lingo,
we'd call this blueprint a definition.
Or we would say that in the Move.swift
file, we define the Move struct.